We've seen some companies
that created  a lot of value
with non-paying customers
got acquired for very
large sums of money.
But ultimately to me,
if customers are paying,
it means they really value
what it is you're delivering.
Lilia Shirman,
thank you so much for joining me.
How are you today?
Great, Michael.
Thanks for having me.
Of course.
Where are you calling from?
I am right in the middle
of Silicon Valley, actually,
in Redwood City, California.
In the middle of Silicon Valley,
Redwood City, California.
So, today, you are the CEO
of the Shirman Group,
an expert in Go-to-Market,
and we'll talk all about that.
We'll talk about the difference
between Go-to-Market and marketing.
And we have quite a long journey
to get through today.
But we have to start all the way back
to your first job,
in college, I believe,
when you were wearing a bunny suit.
So, it's quite a long journey
from wearing a bunny suit to the job
to being the CEO
of a consultancy group in Silicon Valley.
But take me all the way back there
and paint me the picture.
Sure.
So, the summer
after my junior year in college,
I got a job at Applied Materials,
which is a semiconductor
equipment company.
And part of the company I worked with
was the, what was called final test.
So, it was where these very large
multimillion dollar machines,
imagine a minivan sized
piece of equipment
with robotics and gas lines
and vacuum chambers
and all kinds of things,
going through final tests
before they go out
to a semiconductor fab.
And they had to be in a clean room.
So, to get in there,
you have to wear
what's called a bunny suit,
which is this white coverall
because you don't want any
extra particles.
And it becomes,
you don't think about the jargon
you use in your job.
And so, once in a while, I would say,
yeah, I spent all day in a bunny suit.
And people would kind of look at me like,
"What's your job exactly?"
Right.
And I actually ended up staying
in Applied Materials
for about another four years
after graduation.
They kept me
all through senior year and beyond.
So, yeah, that was,
that's my bunny suit story.
And it's not nearly as exciting,
I'm sorry, as one might think.
Well, it's still a great story.
So then, what happened?
So, you're starting out
in Applied Materials,
you spend quite a few years there,
mainly wearing a bunny suit,
and how do you end up
becoming an expert
in Go-to-Market strategy?
Yeah.
So, even then,
because I was in this
the culmination of all the things
that the company did,
my job was
started out being about quality.
So, all the problems you would find
before we were sending the machines out
to the customer
came from all kinds of different places,
whether it was suppliers or assembly,
or a faulty part,
or whatever it may be.
And so, I got a view really early on
into the interconnectedness
of all things,
into how all of the different things
that happened along the supply chain
contribute to the final product.
And so, while still at Applied Materials,
I applied to Stanford graduate school,
I got in.
Applied was kind enough
to give me a fellowship to do that.
So, that was the first step
in what I called
the journey to the dark side.
I did a really cool program
that was in the engineering school,
but had a lot of business school
pieces to it.
And a funny side story about that,
my master's project,
the class produced
what is the gorilla pod,
which is that little stand for cameras
made out of little balls.
Okay.
So, that was the winning team
and we were the runners up.
Wow.
And so, coming out of Stanford,
I got recruited by Accenture,
which is one of the big consulting firms,
their strategy practice.
Right.
And did supply chain strategy
for several years.
So, what does that mean
supply chain strategy?
Like I'm imagining in the day to day,
you have to talk to,
you have to really like,
sit in front of a huge map
and think about
what are the different opportunities
to go to get the products across.
How does that actually look like?
So, some of it is optimization.
How many warehouses where,
how many factories,
the distribution network.
Some of it is more broad.
We did quite a bit of acquisition work.
The Compaq-DEC acquisition,
Ascend and Cascade merged,
which I always thought was funny
because the two names
were exactly opposites.
So, it was bringing together
operations of different companies.
I think a better really descriptor
for what we were doing
was operational strategy.
It wasn't just really
supply chain and logistics.
Although some clients
had Accenture doing that as well.
So, it was sort of a nice segue
between my very geeky
engineering background,
and sort of looking at it
from a business perspective.
And so, I kind of call
my time at Accenture my,
if the MBA wasn't the title
of my master's,
and that those three years
definitely were.
And I ended up doing,
something I knew
absolutely nothing about,
and I joked that that's I like to
every five or six years,
go and start something new
that I know nothing about and learn it
and then go do something else.
So, after Accenture,
I went to BEA Systems,
which is a software company.
And I had no idea
about anything to do with software.
I went into a product marketing role.
I had no idea about marketing.
The reason I ended up there is because
they were diversifying away
from their core technology
into areas that required an understanding
of why integrating data and systems
and so on would matter to our customer.
And that I understood.
So, yeah.
So, they took a chance and they hired
what I thought was the kind of
unqualified person and it was a blast.
It was a blast
to do something really new.
It sounds really fascinating.
And I'd love to transition
and then discuss a little bit about
the idea behind Go-to-Market strategies.
100%, we're seeing
so many different emerging markets today,
so many emerging technologies,
that I get to observe both
as a student at Stanford
from the engineering side,
but also as a member of J-Ventures
from the investment side.
And one of the key questions is always,
how do you bring the products out
to the audience
and not in terms of marketing,
but how do you actually,
what is the chain like to get there?
And it's obviously,
it's a common question
for a small startup
and for a big enterprise.
Can you start Lilia, by explaining to me
what is Go-to-Market fundamentally,
and why is it such a crucial aspect?
And then allude to how your firm
helps companies optimize that.
Yeah.
So, I define go to market very broadly.
To me, it's pretty much everything
a company does
to get its product out
in front of paying customers, right?
Why paying?
Why is that an important piece of it?
Because
if you don't have paying customers,
eventually you run out of cash
and can't do whatever magic
it is you want to do, fundamentally.
And yes, we've seen some companies
that created a lot of value
with non-paying customers,
got acquired for very
large sums of money.
But ultimately, to me,
if customers are paying,
it means they really value
what it is you're delivering.
Right?
And I'm also assuming that
the reason that word is in there
is because the strategy
is inherently different.
A way to acquire a free customer
is very different
than acquiring a paying customer.
It's maybe a different demographic,
different strategy,
different friction to get there.
Yeah. Absolutely, absolutely.
And of course, it's different
between business customers
and consumers as well.
Right, right.
Yeah.
And my focus has definitely been
on the business side.
But I think a lot of the,
the ways that
we think about delivering value
and unifying everything you do
that's customer facing
is very relevant
to both consumers and businesses.
Right.
And so, when I think about
Go-to-Market for younger companies,
there's always when you're pitching
to investors, there's always the slide.
You're told you have to have
a Go-to-Market slide.
And a lot of founders
really struggle with that
because they're thinking,
we don't know yet,
we're early,
or they don't have that expertise
on the team.
And so, that slide is probably
has the largest variation I've seen
in terms of something that makes sense
and something that's just clearly
pulled out of the air
in the last, as an afterthought
to the rest of the presentation.
There are three parts
when I think about Go-to-Market.
There's sort of the strategy,
and the fundamental thing,
the fundamental decision is
who are we serving
and what problem are we solving.
That's really, really simple, right?
And that's something
that you should at least have a,
a good idea or a good thesis about
when you start out, right?
And then the questions to follow
are things like,
by what means
are we solving that problem;
and what mode
are we going to build around it
that's defensible long term.
Those four questions at a startup level
is what you need to answer.
As you grow,
then you get into planning and content
and value propositions
and marketing strategy
and alliances and all the other things
that make up Go-to-Market.
But at the beginning,
those four questions
who, what are we doing for them;
how are we doing it;
and how are we going to keep this
wow and unique,
are the four things
you really need to think about.
Right.
So, it makes perfect sense
that the strategy changes, you know,
on a very regular basis
as the product is changing,
as the team and the world
is obviously changing,
your strategy should be changing.
Is this something that you recommend
thinking from the get go
as you're building the product,
already understanding
this is the strategy
of how I'm going to get it
to the customer?
Or is this at a later stage?
When does it really become
a crucial part of the company,
this Go-to-Market?
So, I think of it in stages, right?
When you were first starting
to conceive the product,
those two questions of
what problem and for whom,
we're going to be really important.
Because they influence
how you design the product.
They influence
how the user interacts with it.
They influence how much you have to plan
to invest in sales and wholesale support,
how you're going to reach that customer.
There's a lot of decisions
that cascade down from those few.
Right.
And so, I would say start thinking about
that really early
because it's going to influence
how much cash you need
and who your competitors are and so on.
So, I would say from the get go.
And then you're going to refine,
you're going to iterate your packaging.
Pricing is going to change.
A lot of things are going to change.
But you've got to have that necessarily.
So, the next question that I have is,
I'm thinking of myself
creating a startup in a few months
with some really great friends
from Stanford, from the Army
or wherever, you know,
we're going to be sitting around,
we are we're going to build, hopefully,
a great product,
and none of us have any experience
in supply chains
and Go-to-Market strategies,
and even thinking about what it takes
to bring a product there,
and obviously, you know,
when we're two weeks old
or two months old,
we're probably not going to bring in
an outside executive to come and do
our Go-to-Market strategy
from the get go.
So, how do you balance
your lack of experience
with the need to have some strategy
playing out?
It's a really easy thing.
You go talk to customers.
Right?
They will tell you.
Don't ever try to do
any piece of Go-to-Market,
even the really early guesses
in the four walls.
The best thing that a team can do
is just go,
really understand  the customers
you think you'll have.
Talk to them about what problem,
ask a lot of questions,
they will tell you.
You don't need an outside expert.
You don't need to hire an expensive CMO,
whatever it may be.
Just go validate, validate
and then go validate again.
Right.
So, one of the things that,
that you said earlier is that
there is a clear distinction
between Go-to-Market and marketing.
And that's something that
I guess is often confused
between the two.
That your marketing strategy
is not necessarily
the Go-to-Market strategy and vice versa.
Right?
I would say Go-to-Market
is just a broader set of decision.
Okay.
Marketing,
I joke that the M word
should be actually banned.
Because it means
so many different things.
Right?
Right.
But ultimately, marketing,
typically is about generating demand
for your product.
But there are a lot of other things
that impact the customer experience.
I'll give you an example.
Look at Apple Computer.
Apple Computer,
you know, when Steve Jobs started,
he understood instinctively
that it's not just about
the functionality of the computer.
It's about the experience.
It's about the interface.
It's about the packaging.
When later on, when they open stores,
it was about every single,
every single thing was in that stuff.
Right?
So, the marketing are the amazing ads,
the word of mouth, and so on.
But Go-to-Market is everything.
It's the decision of
how you're going to distribute
and of having an apple expert
within a Best Buy store, for example.
Right.
There's a lot of things around us that
it's kind of how to build an ecosystem
of partners and developers.
That's all part of Go-to-Market.
Who holds the responsibility
of the Go-to-Market strategy
within our organization,
even as it scales
to tens of thousands of people,
who holds that responsibility?
So, I think it's usually
the chief marketing officer.
Okay.
But it really is
an executive team discussion,
because you have strategic alliances
and product and so on
that also have to be very engaged.
Customer experience now
is usually a separate function.
Wonderful.
So, Lilia, there are so many more topics
that we can discuss.
But I also want to make sure
to hear a little bit about
the book that you wrote,
and some more insights
that you've gained from that,
before I ask you my favorite question
of the interview.
Yeah.
So, the book I wrote is,
42 Rules for Growing Enterprise Revenue.
A lot of rules.
42.
And if you're a fan of Douglas Adams,
you know why 42.
So, why 42?
Because it's the answer to life,
the universe and everything,
Yeah. The meaning of life.
So, it's a distillation really
of the thinking processes and frameworks
that I had used both in my
operational roles and with clients.
And it was a great opportunity
to kind of think through
how do I think about solutions,
how do I think about selecting markets,
how do I think about
relationships with customers
and customer relevance and value.
So, it's a very, you know,
each rule is like two pages.
It's a really quick read.
There's a lot of
different frameworks in there
and it was a lot of fun to write.
I'm sure. Was there a specific trigger
to writing it?
Did you see some pattern forming?
Or is these mainly insights
that you've gained over the years
that you just had to put on paper
and send it to the world?
Well, the trigger was
the publisher approached me and said,
"Write a book."
Okay. That's an amazing trigger.
Yeah. It's a great trigger.
And they already had kind of a format
that you had to follow.
I don't know that I would have written it
quite that way.
I just started from scratch.
But it actually,
when you have to provide an idea
in whatever it is,
600 words to small pages,
you get very, very focused
on the core thing.
100%.
I have to mention to reflect back,
I recently launched a book about
youth entrepreneurship
and some personal experiences.
There was no word limit,
there was no structure.
And it was a very interesting experience,
very different, I guess,
that for me it was just
a plain blank page,
just write the story
and then condense it to sound good.
Now that you're mentioning
this word limit,
I almost wish
I had imposed a word limit on myself
so that I could even condense it more
and feel that I'm focusing more
on these ideas.
But it's a little bit late.
And the book is available,
I'm guessing, on Amazon, to purchase?
Yeah. Yeah.
It's on any online bookstore.
Wonderful.
Okay. So, the 42 rules.
I'm excited to take a look at it myself.
Lilia, I want to thank you
for being so generous with your time.
Thank you for sharing your insights
both about your journey
from the bunny suit,
all the way to the Shirman group
and your expertise on selecting markets
and Go-to-Market strategy.
And in general,
how companies work and operate.
This is exactly why I'm doing this show,
to learn from experts like yourself
that have been, have seen so much.
That a lot of the mistakes
that you've perhaps observed
or the successes you've observed,
as a young entrepreneur,
I can now take that those lessons with me
and hopefully make less of them
on my journey.
So, thank you for that.
And before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Oh, so this was,
you gave me a warning
and it was still hard.
Yeah.
It's not a single word,
but I would say,
short attention span.
Short attention span.
I like that.
I'd say I'm pretty creative.
And
even though I'm creative,
very structured.
I like to create boxes
and inter-relationships
and make very complex things
conceivable.
So, short attention span,
creative and structured,
I think those are,
that's a fantastic combination.
Lillia, thank you very, very much.
Thank you for the inspiration.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you.